Okay. Ready? Yeah. Hey, I'm Jetta.
Boom, rod. And I remember Colbert.
This is Radiolab, our fun drive addition,
when we're trying to prevail upon you,
give you all the reasons we can think
of to support public radio and radio lab
in particular. You know what Robert, why,
why should we even say anything when I
think it's more powerful when somebody
who uses radio lab who uses public
radio can say it for us. Well,
you have someone in mind. I do. I have
a story here that came into our inbox.
This is a true story where public
radio, you ready for this? Okay.
Literally saved a boy's life. What? All
right, so I'm exaggerating a little,
but it helped out in a pretty dire
situation. And if saving lives,
healing wounds doesn't make you want
to support this service, then well,
frankly I don't know what will.
So anyhow, um, the woman who wrote,
we're just going to call her right
now. Her name is Jennifer Bab and how,
how would we be spelling [inaudible]
bad baptism. Yes sir.
Jennifer Bab as MBA. Yes.
That will be via the B.
Yup. And it involves her and
her son. Like
hello. Hi, is this Jennifer? Yes. Hey,
this is Jad and this is Robert here
on the other microphone. Hi Guys.
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet
you telephonically. Now Jennifer,
I understand you have a,
you have a son, right?
Yes, I have two children you might send
is my oldest. He's seven and a half lake
blink. And so can you set the scene
for the story you're gonna tell it?
Well, let's see. So Blake,
um, he says when he grows up,
he's going to be an inventor.
What do you like to build most of all
is airplane airplanes and helicopters.
Okay. So the first one, the
belt were just, you know,
he'd take a couple of pieces of Tupperware
and lay them out on the floor in the
shape of the plane.
But lately he's been trying to
build planes that actually fly.
So he made this airplane.
He's sitting next to me now and he's
telling me it's more like a helicopter.
It's okay.
40 bucks cut out too long.
Propeller blades that he duct taped
together in the shape of an egg.
And the propeller, I have to say
the propeller is really cool.
The propeller actually flies.
So we have kind of a balcony on our
house and he stood up on the balcony and
like flung it off and
then hovered in there
really? Oh Wow. Moment
before falling to the ground.
Okay. So, so you, you, you've done a
bunch of tests with this propeller,
you see that it can fly and then
I'm assuming at a certain point, um,
he takes it to the next step.
Yeah.
So He's been learning about electricity
and about motors and things and he's got
a couple of toys that have motors on them.
So He's been trying to build an airplane
that'll hook up to the motor and he
tried to attach his pillar
and it just fell over.
Yeah. See the motor
wasn't powerful enough.
Right.
And so there's only one thing that
we've got that strong enough to power a
propellor of this size
and IP human beings.
Oh yes.
So what he did was, since
the motor didn't work,
he made out of duct tape a harness system
so that he could kind of climb inside
the harness and hold on to the propeller.
And he's, is he going to twist the
propellors himself while he's flying?
Exactly. Grabbed my do it with his hands
in this kinda like spin to make it fly.
And so, you know, we have this
rock wall that's about, I dunno,
three feet high. And so he
climbed up on the rock wall
and jumped and he said,
you have retraced back.
Really? He felt it. He felt that.
So all kind of weird.
Hi. Hi Blake. Hi. So you felt like, uh,
so where did you jump from?
You jumped from the wall.
Hello? Hello
Blake, are you there? Blake is,
um, he's not a really big talker.
And did you mom know any of this
was happening at this point? Yeah,
I made a movie of it.
So you are aware of his
experiments in flight?
Yeah, well, it's fascinating to watch,
you know, to see how his mind works.
He's learning. Like I said, you
know, every time, every iteration,
you learn something from the
weight of one before fail.
Whoa.
So that was, um, that was in the evening.
That was like eight o'clock at night
and the next day he's was a Saturday or
Sunday and he's fussing
around in the garage. And, um,
my husband and I were in the
kitchen talking about whatever.
And Blake comes walking past with his
harness system on and he walks through the
doors to go into the backyard.
Just walks right through, right? There's
something slightly Calvin and Hobbes,
he about this pill for whatever reason,
not arouse our suspicion as
it should have, you know,
I don't know what we were talking
about. And then, you know, two,
three minutes later we hear the cry.
[inaudible]
you know, the kind of cry that's not,
I'm scared or wham hungry. It's
the cry. That means I'm hurt.
Now just to jump in here.
Jennifer Warren's outside to the backyard
where there's this maple tree and she
looks up and she sees her son
weakly entangled in the tree,
look to her,
like he'd climbed up to the top branch
with the harness of Dumont and then
jumped and got twisted and
he was really, really bloody.
He had scraped the whole back of his leg,
this big like foot long gash and
are just like, oh my God. Oh my God.
Just bleeding all down his leg. And,
and how my husband had to like push
him up so that I could untangle the,
like ropey bits of the duct tape harness
system to get him off and pull him
down. So I, you know,
carried him through through the kitchen
and put 'em on the couch in the living
room
and she says she tried to turn him over
so she could get a look at the cut.
But he kept squirming and
wouldn't let her see it.
And that was the moment it
occurred to me to put on radio lab.
Oh,
capture his imagination. So he buys,
still forget that his leg hurt him and
then I could look at it while he was
distracted.
What gave you that idea?
I don't know. That iPod was kind of
sitting there and I was like, okay,
I'll put on Radiolab and he can
listen to the bit about parasites.
So when you press go or, or begin on
your, on your iPod, what happened?
Oh, he was instantly fascinated. He
listened to the whole entire podcast,
the whole 45 minutes or whatever
it is and yeah, and I was able,
I got his, uh, wound cleaned off to
get a child like that to stop moving,
to stop twitching in some degree.
Like you should see him right now.
He's sitting here like tapping his
feet and playing with this spork. Um,
and you had his attention
from the first moment,
but it goes beyond that.
According to Jennifer,
after she'd been playing him
the show for a few minutes,
she paused it just shortly after a
segment we made about a parasitic wasp.
What it does is it flies around
and it looks for a cockroach.
That's the one. And she asked him,
did you understand any of that?
And he repeated it back to me. Yeah.
Almost word for word. Maybe
we should put Blake on. Yeah.
Okay. Let me go get them.
They are ready to talk to you.
Hi.
Hi. So we want to hear like what can
you remember about the radio show?
The one that parishes was um,
the parish wast is flying around.
Then it finds cockroach
that finds that cockroach.
They tumbled back and forth around.
Patricia Gwas mentioned this, stab it
in the stomach, right in the belly,
the cockroach, which is for a second.
And then it this fault
go and it's stings it.
The Stinger actually
started threads its way
to a particular spot in the brain
in a way they can
control the clock colors.
This stands up.
And so now the hall sits by the end,
the cockroaches contento
and start pulling out, down, down,
down, down.
He lays eggs and say the
cockroach. And then the eggs hatch.
You remember the entire story?
Yes. Jennifer too is flabbergasted.
And she says she turned to him
and was like, wow, Blake, what?
Excellent listening comprehension. You
have, you do understand what you hear.
And he said yes,
but I don't understand when
people are talking to me.
You mean like he doesn't understand that
when people talk at him or lecture him?
Yeah,
like when I'm in trouble I never
understand what you're talking about.
And so I did have the thought that if
only I had the means I could record some
of my lectures so that
I could play them back.
You know with the right sound effects,
that's the baby you would have that the
same like it tends to be of listening to
what I was trying to say.
Those two mothers everywhere,
mothers across America,
we were paying millions of
dollars for these lectures.
Which brings me to a really quick pitch.
Public radio is all about
making stories stick.
That's what we try and do at radio
lab and all the shows. Try and do,
do you have um, lecturers
off the top of your head?
Because if you give them to us
we could give them back to you.
And in that radio lab five version.
See there, I guess there is, there's
one thing, and this is, you know,
this kind of gets at the whole climbing
up into a tree with propellers.
Like you have to think things
all the way through to the end.
Hmm. Jennifer says she said
that to Blake millions of times.
She's not sure if it ever gets through
things through to the end.
So we thought we would try
and give her a new spin on it.
I don't know if this is going to
work, but hey, let's give it a shot.
Here is our, uh, attempt to
make a sticky lecture for Blake.
Have to think things all the way through
[inaudible]
thing all the way. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks.
Thanks all the way through.
I think saying all the way,
all the way,
like what your mom is saying is that
when you want to have an adventure or
prevent something,
don't just think about the beginning of
it or what you think might happen in the
middle, in your mind. Take
it all the way through.
You know, it's okay to test
your theories. You know,
I encourage experimentation.
The only way you're
going to learn is if you fail.
She's not just saying that. I mean,
Take Thomas Edison, the king inventor,
he tried to invent a battery
and he failed 10,000 times,
but he needed to think about,
so you have to kind of consider
what kind of the best outcome,
the worst outcome, and imagine that
both of those things have happened.
Like imagine the scenario in
your mind and what you include.
Okay, let's do that. Scenario one,
you're in the tree, this is the good one.
And you see
being on the blade round, round,
round and round and round
and round and round in.
It works.
You're, you're flying all
through the neighborhood.
So here's the question. You've
got to answer. What happens next?
What he hasn't thought is, for
example, how is he going to land?
Hmm. So you gotta take it all the
way through to the landing part.
Now let's play out the other scenario.
The one where things don't go well.
Let's say you jump out of the tree and
you crash and you really hurt yourself.
Well think of how sad your
mom would be and your dad
and your sister
cases where you make up a little movie
in your head and you play it all the way
through and hopefully the good
one will happen, the best outcome.
But just in case you'll now be prepared
so that you can mitigate
the effects. Worst outcome.
And I probably wouldn't
say mitigate to my child,
so we're going to do something with
this lecture and send it to you.
Uh Huh.
No, seriously. Well thanks you
guys. I'll talk to you. Yes.
And we have no absolutely no connection
to any kind of further experimentation
of this kind of love yourself
and responsibility on his own.
Okay. Alright. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Right, bye.
[inaudible]
no, I don't exactly know what to say here,
but there is something about this story
that just kind of like gets to the whole
point of why we do this. Yeah.
And here you've got this kid
who's obviously in a lot of pain,
and he just sits still and listens
to a story about parasites.
You know what we're trying to do
here is tell stories that move you.